today I'm gonna talk through a little
bit did you want to talk about how you
lost so that one guy had never played
the game before or should we just forget
about that happen no it's fair that it
happened and what the deal is I will say
this I'll let him kind of start to win
and then there came a point where I was
too far behind then you're like [ __ ] no
I wasn't good enough at gore yet to deal
with like if I play a poker player to
play a lot you know they're doing random
things right so yeah that's my excuse no
not also I'm not as good at normal kind
of a lot of people um you're pretty good
getting better all right so this Goro
cotton warrior he has good regulars yeah
absolutely it's common what do we start
with um I think the one everybody wants
to see hashtag if you could all right
now go to Twitter yeah and hash tag
punches last tag punch walk we want to
see how many times a punch walk gets us
out there
let's create a trending trim pom-pom I
got a hashtag hunch walk so we got punch
walk here which I love and then also PX
punch walk would give you a pop up man
so you know one thing it's not really is
that it's a special move but a really
good thing with gore when you start
playing him is his on PlayStation before
axe on xbox before a he has it's a kick
which is a little bit of a stunt and
sure so you can do like kick even in the
punch walks
all right I feel like you should be able
to do anything in the country
authorizers like throw in defensive
punch walking diploma clock absolutely
then the one I just showed you there he
has a command grab which kind of changes
there is different variations Austin
he's got that and then he can also we
get some meter here you can do I can
jump back he's got a jumping kit I can
do this you're a big slam another thing
we've talked about this in the past a
thing called footsies we discuss yeah
another really good tool for that as a
special movie as in this variation which
is he can do Oh
chest up like that chest bump or chest
bump like this and beep slam awesome and
sorry we should go back to another one
this thing that happens in a lot of is
you got excited their chest bump
he also do a smash I mean his his stomp
stomp probably most known for right and
the great thing is like you will track
if you just do it regularly real track
when the opponent bottom is dead but if
I think they might back that I might
work forward - or I can actually throw
it behind them ok or throw it in front
of them so I think they're gonna move
sure so they always have to be guessing
whatever because because if if it was
just the stomp I could - out of the way
around one thing I write he also has in
all variations a projectile projectile
booby can he exit for a little more
damage as well
and then finally in this variation he
has and that's fullscreen - it is and
one of I don't know what yeah yeah you
always play video game you find what
animation that is like kind of your
favorite thing for no reason real I
totally agree with you one of my
favorites this is the X version where he
goes that's awesome so you know Jack
with partner with Goro you can start
doing stuff like doing that and then you
can start doing projectiles and roars
stomp or go up and get having them up so
Goro's great up close but oddly that has
a pretty good game from there that's
awesome so that is a the quartet worrier
okay I personally and this is no bull I
love playing as go around yeah
like I love big characters who throw
people around and or
just so much fun and you can punch more
I don't know if you said that look at
this double double punch walking awesome
so let's move on to another variation so
what do we got
we're oh I just did that with the new
players like I say it's you know those
stream jitters I guess you know after
all of these streams I've run out of
stream bitters except when I fight you
you know all right let's do giant cage
cuz I think you still owe $500 were you
gonna say
I have my sunglasses Goro maybe we'll
get that in trouble
George don't you owe me some sunglasses
what are the chances on that sunglasses
go awesome
so Oh going right for that oh we're not
I know you want to
is that ready positive you gotta like a
treatment I'm gonna look at some just
look at some certain things of maybe
they has one basic attack and this kind
of just shows you how the screens work
to like this shows what are all the
different combo strings one
yeah what's exclusive to that barrier so
if you know all the other moves and you
just kind of want to get quickly to
what's exclusive to this one you know
tab over to that looks like he's got a
coot he's got a bad guy new uh he's got
a new quick knockdown like that one of
the big things here you can get a little
closer apps I love to do is do a little
hash tag punch walk into those new sorry
dragon this dragon spin thing here
really cool really get the meter so you
can do the top up oh I love it yeah so
boom boom boom in the grab and this
command wrap is different now to uses
blades Brett is filled of orangutangs
yep just stops you on the ground so
little little differences here with him
with this one it kind of adds some new
ways to fight in your combo styles as
well so sorry sorry you're good I love
combo you do you do okay let me get all
the way a second cool
but all this beat you up a little bit
maybe we can do a lot let's try this
let's try this okay oops that you you
nailed that kick BAM
there we go I love those stretches
amount
you know I would feel good at the same
time like you need a good back stretch
Yeah right
you sure do yeah and Goro is also like
you just like a lot of bigs gentle
gentle if you give them in the corner
they can do a lot of cool stuff to show
oh did you show the thing with the hose
me this that great waist is the roof so
you can raise the roof with Goro
absolute like this keep the pop-up going
drop the cutoff Mutombo that would've
been a graph yeah yeah abso no I I could
picture it in my head and the gore was
definitely awesome in the corner cuz he
also has a load he has low starter which
you can do low to puff lock sure right
into that under that Oh like you played
this hair it's like I have played this
character before do you know them oh
you're not letting the stream down this
we got one more and this next one is uh
you know we've talked about the about
variations for a long time and how they
work in the game just like let's say you
love Goro
but maybe the up close game isn't your
favorite part we have a version for you
Tigra fury tiger fury which uses a lot
of complaints oh okay Luke a good call
we call well you know I'm just trying to
keep it keep it with the story that's
about it are we still have to take a
punch walk the only way we should be
yeah
hashtag punch walk nice song there yeah
well you know I tried to make platinum
hits all day long it's what I did
dropping them hits and then beats with
the aid of Shang Tsung's magic versus
the Lord Ling alright so now he's added
some special things here now Luke a
house fire sure oh yes about you yeah
right
so does Goro okay so he can also shoot
holy really woody TX's those absolutely
cool he also has OH
equip we're at the fire so you know you
can you can he exit for more damage mmm
one of my favorites that he does is you
can do a little of this a quick stop in
to nothing
my bad there it is okay BAM you could
knock him up where you can do a bigger
knock up and then going into the combos
awesome so he's definitely a real fun
version to play when it comes to like
zoning things after
you know we should see if the this build
has the second fatality a lot I think
that would be amazing
do you think you can handle doing it yep
yeah all right I just wanna do some more
punch walking okay okay we get some
meter just achieve it out a little bit
oh oh
Cup steps like that you know I want to
uh they figure you know if the man grab
you don't and you can combo the ground
blast also from there to right yeah I
have a practice that much bring that up
sorry mute except me a video once they
know that you're a pathetic so see I
would take the arms has the best sense
of humor when it comes to things like
that
he probably right alright so that's
pretty much the three character
breakdowns yeah that is the time let's
do a little talk to the community a
little bit and sort of